Vậy, bây giờ mình phải nghĩ này, mình phải xí di cầu dị.
Không ai chứ giấu trắng là được gánh nhau.
Thì trong những bạn đó mà không ai chứ giấu trắng là được gánh nhau.
Nó thì chúng ta đang ai chứa chứa cây trường hợp của rời trở xuất trắng.
Mình không biết là số lượng số trắng mà như của thì có một số trắng của thì có 2 số trắng,
3 số trắng của trắng của trắng.
Thì mình không biết là, có năng chứ số lời có là được trắng.
Thì không có số trắng mà, hồi được năng được.
số số trắng, có năng chứ số tựa cái.
Nên số số trắng của mình đã năng chứ số tựa cái của mình không được năng.
Được chào, như khu dễ là khu không được của số nè thôi, nên kéo dị mình phải có 1 số trắng.
Bục khu dễ là năng, mình không ai chứa được gánh nhau.